[Musica]
ciao ragazzi oggi nuovo episodio di
gregni ha nascosto gli ingredienti lo
scorso episodio che è piaciuto
tantissimo ha raggiunto un milione di
views e avete lasciato 43 mila mi piace
siete fantastici davvero incredibile e
mi avete continuato a chiedere ogni
giorno un secondo episodio mi avete
chiesto di andare in stanze diverse
allora oggi siamo in un piano
completamente diverso della casa che non
l'avete mai visto ed è molto grande
quindi sarà ancora perde per tratte
intra far troppo rumore bach e treni e
qui da qualche parte comunque lasciato
un bel mi piace a questo video e se
questo video raggiunge il 50 mila mi
piace fare una terza parte con g per chi
non avesse visto l'altro video con
funziona praticamente io devo recuperare
tutti gli ingredienti slime senza farmi
sentire beccare da granny o cinque
giorni a disposizione se non riesco a
recuperare tutti gli ingredienti nei
cinque giorni ho perso se invece riesco
a fare lo stein quindi ad attivarlo ea
mettere gli ingredienti dentro ho vinto
e treni scomparirà quindi mi raccomando
fate il tifo permessa questo succederà
oggi
finora non l'ho né vista né sentita alla
porta in chiosa guardate
non penso che sia chiuso a chiave perché
nel genere lei chiude a chiave solo dopo
che ti ha beccato però se troppo
silenzio e mi fa molto strano la cosa ho
paura che sia nascosta qua in giro
comunque mettetevi comodi prendevi i pop
corn e iniziamo subito l'avventura
razzi giorno 1
mi devo guardare intorno a devo vedere
se c'è qualche ingrediente qua in questa
stanza speriamo perché altrimenti devo
aprire la porta e andare di là e non so
perché ho come la sensazione che i treni
sia lì allora controlliamo asean in
questa stanza e vediamo assieme mi
raccomando anche voi dovete aiutarmi se
vedete qualche ingrediente qualcosa
scrivetelo nei commenti
ho sentito un rumore avete sentito
andiamo a vedere non so se controllare
[Musica]
e aperta la porta ok ragazzi per fortuna
la porta era aperta guardate
tutto pure paura che se funziona il
professore di preferenza conti spazio
qui si può nascondere tre anni in cui mi
potrei nascondere anch'io forse è tutto
buio non so seconda freccia mostri store
è enorme ed ora che corre nel avete
vista passata si riformi zio di oggi
piedi dobbiamo fare con calma e piano
fortini ok ok
[Musica]
ancora lì e la porta la fede te non so
perché non è addio
[Musica]
magia da chiave maledetti
ok allora abbiamo capito che io penso
che sia ancora lì al rapporto attaccata
quindi è meglio non uscire adesso ma
cerchiamo di perlustrare questa stanza
vediamo se troviamo qualcosa sia ancora
lì alla porta però allora voglio
controllare bene se qua c'è qualche
ingrediente questi non devo uscire da
fuori anche se non ho visto niente
sarebbe troppo facile si trovasse
qualcosa qua in questa stanza
[Musica]
purtroppo non vedo niente dove potrebbe
essere nascosti
poi vedete qualcosa qua c'è una pianta
una casetta
oddio che paura che cos'è questo lo
faccia gigante ricordarti con 8 forse
c'è qualche qualche cosa nascosta dentro
questo vaso o paure a toccarlo magari un
maledetto e strano stranissimo devo
provare a toccarlo prodotto carlo spero
che non succeda niente poteri chiama
granny poi o si mette a urlare perché
chiarita un vago non può urlare
ok no è un passo normale
penso anche se un po particolare come
vado ma aspetta un momento che cos'è
quella cosa là sopra
lo vedete pezzo di plastica e pulsante
che cosa vorrà dire
secondo voi dopo premerlo potrebbe
richiamare granny però potrebbe magari
degli ormai questo ma gli ingredienti su
cosa fare che forzano premo non lo premo
ditemelo voi lo pure come lo prego e va
bene lo prego sono troppo curiosa cox
[Applauso]
bicarbonato unicorno ho sentito dire
si metta
[Musica]
via
ha lasciato la porta aperta
ho fatto mi sembra di sentire niente che
borsate ha detto che il carbonato
unicorno non ho idea di cosa voglia dire
per forza uscire da questa stanza per
trovare qualche ingrediente ok ragazzi
mi sono dunque sostanza piano pià
io
[Musica]
grazie poi tua madre ma io non torno
e penso che ci sia qualcosa
questa cosa
penso io
reja
[Musica]
hanno credimi ha beccato siamo il
secondo giorno devo riuscire a prendere
il tutto quattro giorni ma sono riuscito
a prenderla lo stesso la soluzione per
lenti treni l'aveva messa dentro la
cloche così sapeva che avrei fatto
rumore maledetta ma l'importante che
sono riuscito a prenderla e poi mi
sembra di aver visto qualcos'altro un
fondo nella stanza dove c'era la
trappola
c'era un altro pulsante non so se mi può
servire per darmi qualche indizio o poi
vengo beccata di sicuro quindi dovrei
sacrificare un giorno forse si sa
qualcosa lì intorno
proviamo a dare un'occhiata mi
raccomando questa nasconde dentro la mia
cassettina casomai premi venga a
riprenderla
ecco tutto ok
piano piano gli store dimentica che
entrare in chiude sempre rapporto capito
che ti becca un maledizione
ora devo fare rumore con qualcosa per
farla entrare e nascondermi
chissà che questa volta prima mi
nascondo e poi faccio il rumore
altrimenti come l'altra volta potrebbe
beccarvi prima
[Musica]
ok è così un qua dentro
devo chiudere l'accordo altrimenti crei
minestra porta arriva
[Musica]
eccola lì
ok mi ha fatto via possiamo uscire dalla
casetta piano piano e dirigerci verso la
trappola qualche ingrediente li vede
pronti abbiamo piano
ennesimo cercare di non fare l'amore
[Musica]
ok quando era lì
la donna
abbiamo strada andiamo
c'è
[Musica]
ci sono premere un pulsante
o no ho perso un altro giorno e in più
non si capiva quasi niente di cosa
diceva quel bottone mi sembra che
dicesse se il bicarbonato voi
acchiappare non parlare vita vuol dire
poi perché entrambi i bottoni parlavano
di bicarbonato forse deve essere la cosa
più difficile da trovare a questo punto
anche perché ho trovato finora solo un
ingrediente ho paura che lo perderò
veramente questa charlene
vabbè comunque non ho tempo per
risolvere indovinelli devo trovare
almeno la colla e una ciotola una
spazzola altrimenti perderò la challenge
di sicuro anche se penso di avere poche
possibilità ormai questa volta è molto
più difficile in questa stanza non c'è
un bel niente anche perché
sarebbe troppo facile sono quindi
sicuramente dovrò uscire per ripescare
granny aspetto commento ma che cos'è
questa cosa non sei ci credono a
quadrato il tempo non me ne sono accorta
e una trottola un contenitore o in
palestra
così è stato per farlo c'è qualcosa
dentro poi piano ci sono the kids are
dentro e una ciotola per fare dello slam
peccato che mi manca ancora la colla e
il bicarbonato di sodio e la spatola che
altrimenti non riesco a fare niente
perché non lo mischio con le mani ma non
ha molto senso comunque detto anche
queste cose nella mia casetta così
grandi nomi le ruba proviamo a beccare
una coppia dobbiamo riuscire ad esso
e sapete cosa vuol dire che mi devo
nascondere nuovamente per far entrare g
che casino che ha fatto
[Musica]
sì
dipende
ok è andata via
usciamo dalla casetta e cerchiamo di
trovarlo a colle
[Musica]
ecco
sì o no
sarà chiusa come forza prendere
stai attento marco non si è chiusa chi
sa come sia pure troppo buio
trascorrendo
ti alla russia
fare brand
questo fino a che si perde
io prendo si è accorto
vero è sembrato si era visto qualcosa
[Musica]
così poi avrò più tempo ma che c'è qui
sotto non c'era niente ma che cavolo
ok ho deciso di prendere solo una colla
perché non so perché mi aveva un brutto
presentimento
mi sembrava una trappola di green e cioè
che se avessi preso in tutte e tre le
colle sarebbe scattato qualche allarme
qualcosa
sono sicura che c'era qualche trappola
in mezzo quindi ho deciso di prendere
solo questa che è la più luminosa
ecco fatto ne ho messo poco così poi
sarà più facile da attivare
ora metto un po dic l'inter e non posso
ancora mentre la stessa interventi
perché non ho ancora trovato il
bicarbonato
quindi ora mi passa da trovare solamente
il bicarbonato e la paletta che tirare
il tutto e se riesco a trovarli ce l'ho
fatta
i ragazzi andiamo finora premi non si
sente forse c'è qualcosa che sostavano
che cos'è
non ci credi
mirko loro aspetto
[Musica]
questo non mi ricorda il pulsante diceva
un ato unico orno giusto quindi forse
il bicarbonato stacco attento ai saperi
e pulsante dice la tv libica si indicano
nato voi a trattare non devi parlare di
una cosa del genere
ora sì basta prendere il ri carbonato
hit come cavolo sei di tutti se volessi
non prendervi carbonato
[Musica]
o no grani mi ha beccato nuovamente ma
non mi ricordo bene cosa è successo
c'era un cavolo di pappagallo che
parlavo e faceva in modo che i trenini
beccasse forse erano d'accordo per ora
capisco perché il bottone diceva se il
bicarbonato voi aggrappare non dovrei
parlare qualcosa del genere perché c'era
una trappola questa volta la trappola
era diversa dal solito era il pappagallo
che ripeteva quello che dicevo ma questa
volta che so come funziona non mi frega
starò zitta tutto il tempo quindi mi
dispiace che non parlerò con voi ma devo
stare in completo silenzio 6 il
bicarbonato quindi mi toccherà a
mischiare lo slime con le mani perché
non ho idea di dove sia la palette
pochissimo tempo
questo è il penultimo giorno se mi becca
oggi avrò solo domani quindi spero di
riuscire a prendere il bicarbonato
questa volta farò silenziosissima non
avevo neanche notato che i gremi era
dietro di me
sono sicuro che voi volevate avvertirmi
in qualche modo ora purtroppo devo farla
entrare mi è sembrato che fosse davanti
alla porta comunque
cosa vuoi sono mi nascosi ha solo la
casetta poi mi nascondo dietro al titano
un po di rumore quindi su questo cuscino
avrà fatto pure abbastanza adesso questo
punto non c'è
[Musica]
all
sarà una realtà
[Musica]
credimi ha beccato di nuovo
questo è l'ultimo giorno se non prendo
il bicarbonato oggi avrò perso la
challenge
ora si fa nuovamente farle entrare ma
questa volta non mi nasconderò dietro il
divano fatto proprio una cavolata
nascondervi là dietro perché mi ha
beccato sotto rimango qua dentro la
casetta su questo
[Musica]
ok possiamo andare
devo stare attenta
[Musica]
per fortuna roma sentite dentro
è un ragazzo sono riuscito a prendere il
cestino in questi sono tutti gli altri
ingredienti allora innanzitutto sono
riuscito a prendere il bicarbonato e
andiamo subito a metterlo ed era il più
difficile di tutti ne metterò pochissimi
di questi i letterati vicino a me
soprattutto chi sono caduti i battenti
speriamo che si stimi subito questo
slide mescoliamo film è ancora un po
psicologo ma abbiamo fatto
super divertente ma anche molto pauroso
mi raccomando lasciate un bel mi piace
se volete vedere una terza parte a 50
mila mi piace si sbloccherà la terza
parte e ora mi lascio a 4 caselline su
cui cliccare per vedere i miei altri
video cliccate su quella che preferite e
buona visione